German-language premiere at the
Tiroler Landestheater in Innsbruck
synchronization in the birch forest by Victor
Francke
the 78-year-old psychiatrist is
the founder of what is known as logotherapy,
as his theory of
man's search for the meaning of life is
called. Franke had the dramatic peak in
creations in the birch forest during
his imprisonment in the concentration camp
conceived and written down after the war
frankenberg by
trying to cope with the experience of total suffering different levels of
eternity and reality superimposed theater and
reality in the birkenwald camp while
the brothers franz and karl and other
prisoners from eternity by the
philosophers socrates cantons users
and the  dead mother observes between
the piece and frank the
scientific work there are of course connections
the work is a symbol of
this scientific activity
namely to the effect that
finding meaning is made possible through the search for meaning s  oll and
so that our existence is transformed into a meaningful one
for the purpose of
peace peace values performance and peace
for the world and what do you think
I will of course keep quiet then
ou can tell me right away he said as al
ays and what should I do about a brother  do
why why i don't confess a single point of
view well
today i'm grandpa has he i want to make my
life meaningful according to his
theory
today and doesn't fit with a meaningful
then that's an argument comes
from a problem what am i
always  preached again that leighton
is part of life
also has the suffering i have to say
but if you give the stands you
should first prove yourself then it was
n't as long you talk only as soon as
you proved it then only then you have
made it true i still have  too little information about it
cable extends from a tree